- Décision remarquée
de la Cour suprême :
le plus haut tribunal du pays
clarifie des concepts importants
entourant le con
et le port du condom
dans les rapports sexuels.
- La Cour suprême qui trace
clairement la ligne, c'est
certain que c'est rassurant
pour toutes les personnes qui
ont eu à vivre cette forme
d'agression sexuelle.
- Au coefaire,
la cause d'un homme de
la Colombie-Britannique qui
n'avait pas mis de préservatif
lors d'une relation sexuelle
avec uneavec uneavec uneavec un.
Il avait porté un condom lors
d'un premier rapport sexuel,
mais pas lors du deuxième,
à l'insu de la plaignante.
La Cour ordonne un nouveau
procès et statue qu'une personne
qui est tenue par son partenaire
de porter un condom pendant
une relation sexuelle
mais qui ne le fait pas
pourrait être coupable
d'agression sexuelle.
WALID HIJAZI,
avocat-criminaliste
- Si, en cours de route,
on retire le condom ou
si on fait semblant d'avoir
mis un condom alors que dans
les faits, il n'y en avait pas,
"je n'ai jamais consenti
à cette activité",et c'est de f,
une agression sexuelle.
- C'est une forme d'agression
sexuelle qui se produit
quand même assez souvent.
- Une victoire pour
les groupes qui luttent contre
les violences sexuelles, alors
que le phénomène du "furtivage"
est de plus en plus mis
en lumière, cest-à-dire
le retrait furtif du condom
à l'insu du partenaire.
MÉLANIE LEMAY, mouvement Québecs
- Il y a beaucoup de mythes
entourant l'usage du condom,
comme par exemple que c'est
inconfortable, que c'est
moins intéressant, excitant.
Donc, nécessairement,
il y en a beaucoup qui
se permettent de le faire
et ça peut mener à toutes
sortes de conséquences graves,
t'sais, je pense à des
grossesses non désirées.
- Le jugement changera aussi
la donne en matière de violence
conjugale, croit cette avocate.
Me JUSTINE FORTIN, dir. violence
conjugale et sexuelle, Juripop
- C'est le coeur même de ce
qu'on appelle le contrôle
coercitif. C'est le coeur
même de priver son partenaire
d'une liberté de choix.
Et puis, on oublie que
la notion d'agression sexuellee,
elle est extrêmement présente,
voire toujours présente,
dans les relations où il y a
de la violence conjugale.
une fois, une fois, une fois, ,
la Cour suprême juge
nécessaire de clarifier
la notion de consentement.
Elle avait déjà précisé
expressément
renouvelé et communiqué
à chacun des actes sexuels.
Et avec ce jugement,
aucune zone grise : consentir
peut être conditionnel
à l'utilisation du condom.
Ici Louis Blouin,
Radio-Canada, Ott